Hi guys, this is Luca from LucaLampariello.com and today we're going to
deal with the second section of the Q&A
that we're going to see today. Thank you
very much for all the questions that you
have asked me and keep asking the questions
in the comment section below please.
Today, we're going to look at - I have I
hold a piece of paper here - four questions
in four different languages and we're
going to start with English.
Thank you very much happier on a horse I don't know your real name, just your YouTube name and I'll
get to you in a second, let me put this down. So, imagine a prism and imagine this prism
- to be differentiated from prison -  so a
prism that is hit by light - normally
that's the way we can dissect light and
we can see the multiple components of
light. Human beings are like that prism
and languages are those different colors
of light that we can see I don't think
that speaking languages changes my
personality per se because I always have
my own personality but it shows
different facets of my personality so I
think that the more languages you speak
the more facets of your personality you
can actually show to the rest of the
world and you can discover yourself and
of course I do change my cospeech gestures my
hand gestures, my facial features, the
movement of my body, the way I'm speaking
now the very same gestures I'm using now
are not the gestures I would use if I
were speaking Italian but that's just an
external code of communicating I'm just
using a different channel,
so remember: my personality does not
change but what changes is the colorful
possibilities that I have to show my
soul to the rest of the world now on to
the second question asked by Raul
Carvajal in French so I will reply in
French. Hi Luca, which was your first motivation
to learn other languages. Are there languages you have started and given up on
because you lost interest?
The first languages that I learned at school  - didn't have much choice there - were English
and French, they were the only  languages available
so I didn't make any deliberate decision, I just had to learn them.
After that, I started learning German because I had seen some ad on TV about a course
and a friend of my parents spoke German really well, and I had heard that German was a really interesting language,
that German philosophy and literature are very rich, and that's how it all started.
I started learning Spanish with the same exact course I had used to start learning German
and it had worked so well that I gave it a shot with Spanish as well.
After that, I met a Dutch girl in Sardinia, and I started learning Dutch,
and there are other specific reasons for each language I have learned.
It varied according to various circumstances
As for the second question, I started learning Romanian around 6 years ago (actually 9 years ago*),
and I gave up on it, and I gave up on it because..well we are here outdoors, well..
so if you hear dogs, cats and birds, that's normal.. started learning Romanian
because I told myself that I wanted to learn a relatively easy language,
together with a more difficult language - which was Japanese -
and I ended up giving up on both, and I gave up on Romanian because..well, Romanian is a relatively easy language,
but I think that the really problem was that I didn't find native speakers.
or maybe I didn't want to find native speakers, people to talk to,
so I didn't establish relationships with people, I didn't start using the language
and I didn't get passionate about it, I think that's the real reason why I gave up on Romanian,
I didn't feel the passion - I really need to use a language somehow when I start using it.
As far as Japanese is concerned, I made a video about it, where I talked about the fact that I started learning
through a method that didn't work that well for this specific language, so it has slowed me down a lot
and it has discouraged me, especially because Japanese is a rather complicated language. The third question
from Chile that's his name from Chile
and he has asked me this question in Spanish
Luca, I have a big doubt: you mentioned that at the very beginning, during the first 6 months,
what you do is to translate texts in order to learn a language, but my doubt is
how can you translate without knowing much about grammar or vocabulary
because the task is not to translate a paragraph by throwing the text into Google Translate,
or translating it by looking up every single word, how do you do that
without having any foundation in your target language? It is a necessary question
for me and for many others, thanks a lot Luca
Greetings from Chile. Ok. In order to reply to your question, I would say
that you can't start from scratch by using texts you randomly find on the internet,
You have to find texts which are COMPREHENSIBLE and which are
possibly bilingual and which come with audio. This is the reason why I always
this bidirectional Translation Technique to ASSIMIL, which is a series
for those who want to learn foreign languages, because it provides a bilingual text
and this format gives me the possibility of using my mother tongue and my target language
in order to translate back and forth. So, I don't need to translate..I don't need to look up vocabulary
or find grammar explanations because everything is already well explained there. If I want to, I can simply compare
the structure of the 2 languages, and on top of that, if there are things or points that I do not understand by simply comparing the two languages, I can always take a look at the grammar
explanation that are there. So my piece of advice is
in order to implement the Bidirectional Translation you need to get hold of material
which is both comprehensible and enjoyable, and this is the most important point, and
thanks to the internet, you don't necessarily have to use ASSIMIL, you could use podcasts,
other material and resources that you can find on the internet,
provided, once again, that this material be comprehensible
that is with audio, with text - a transcription of the audio itself and you could use
Google Translate that in many cases allows one
keep resorting to an efficient bidirectional translation.
And now on to the fourth
and final question that Marvelenia asked.
Hi Luca I have figured out that it is very important
to take care of how one eats,
because eating well allows you to keep a clear head and engage longer in one's activities.
Also drinking enough (water) is important. A vegan diet with lots of raw food and little sugar
has turned out to be the best option for me. I would be interested in
hearing your opinion, thanks and lovely greetings.
Thanks for the question Marvelenia. It is somewhat funny -
I have been making an effort to address questions (about language learning)
since a lot of people ask me all the time "how do you learn a foreign language"
but recently I have realized and understood that in order to learn a language well, you have to take care of yourself (first and foremost), and in this regard, 3 things are
really relevant, and they are: eating well, sleeping well, and avoid distractions.
Since I started to wake up early, to make my bed,
I have started to avoid turning on my phone and staring at it
since I have started to replace it with reading, I have started eating a fruit at breakfast,
eating a lot of beans and vegetables during the day, go to bed early, everything has started changing
I have more willpower, more energy, I focus better, I wake up and I feel like learning
learning languages, going for a run in the park, working
and that's why taking care of yourself is quite important. Recently I have read a very interesting book
that talks about how the Internet is changing the way our mind works, and I think that we all have
a big problem when it comes to focusing, and I think that
in order to learn languages, you should work on yourself
and on your concentration. So there you have it I've entered these four questions in
four different languages if you want to
know more please ask in the comment
section below. Thank you for all the very
interesting questions that you've been
asking so far and I'm eager to reply to
more in more languages.
Thank you very much for listening to me
and see you very soon here on YouTube
bye.
you